et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Sophie beau bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous diriger SOS
Méditerranée que vous avez cofondé ces 7
ONG qui a fret le bateau de sauvetage le
chêne Viking dont on a beaucoup parlé
ces dernières semaines est-ce que le
bateau a repris la mer à l'heure où l'on
se parle alors le bateau est en Escal
technique alors on se parle on a fait
une longue rotation en mer plus d'un
mois en mer avec comme vous le savez 234
escapés à bord donc il y a beaucoup de
choses à mettre en place avant de
pouvoir repartir en mer et puis on avait
aussi des travaux qui étaient prévus et
donc qui doivent être menées sur le sur
le bateau il repartira en mission
j'imagine les 234 personnes que le chien
Viking a sauvé d'une naufrage donc et
dont on a beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines ont été débarquées à Toulon en
France donc le 11 novembre dernier après
plusieurs semaines d'air en pleine mer
on va y revenir c'est réfugiés ont
d'abord été placés dans un centre
d'accueil dans le sud de la France où il
ne serait aujourd'hui plus que
quelques-uns est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles est-ce vous savez où ils sont
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles SOS
Médecins puisqu'en fait la mission des
sauveteurs s'arrête au moment où nous
débarquons les personnes dans un lieu
sûr ce lieu sûr c'est le port de Toulon
qui a accueilli ces rescapés et donc ce
sont les autorités françaises et
quelques associations en Suisse qui sont
habilités à organiser cet accueil des
personnes et à traiter leur situation
administrative et donc malheureusement
nous nous n'avons plus de nouvelles ce
qui est un petit peu compliqué
effectivement pour nos équipes qui ont
passé trois semaines à bord avec ces
personnes l'équipage a passé
effectivement plusieurs semaines à bord
avec avec ses rescapés c'est naufragés
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il parlait de
leurs intentions de la façon dont il
voyait des choses après une fois qu'ils
auraient pu qu'ils auraient débarqué
alors assez peu finalement parce que ces
trois semaines c'était vraiment une
attente interminable vers
une incertitude vers où allait-on
débarquer on n'avait pas du tout
d'informations on était nous à bord
notre équipe totalement dans
l'incapacité de leur dire quoi que ce
soit sur
la fin de cette très très longue
séquence de sauvetage je rappelle que
c'est la plus longue séquence de
sauvetage que nous avons connue chez SOS
Méditerranée près de trois semaines pour
les premières personnes qui ont été
secourues entre le 22 et le 26 octobre
et donc non en fait toute l'attention de
ces personnes se concentrer sur enfin à
quel moment et où va-t-on pouvoir
débarquer ensuite leur parcours bon
chacun ont des rêves différents des
projets différents des pays n'importe
pas le pays
si ce qui était important c'était de ne
pas retourner en Libye puisque toutes
ces personnes ont pour point commun
d'avoir fui des conditions de ce
qu'elles ont ce qu'elles appellent
l'enfer libyen en Libye elles ont été
prises dans des réseaux de traite
humaine et soumises à des violences
inimaginables pour certaines avec
beaucoup de séquelles des tortures on a
pu voir nos équipes à bord votre équipe
médicale a été confrontée effectivement
cette cette très très douloureuse
séquence de la Libye qui marque et qui
traumatise ces personnes avec des
séquelles des blessures parfois beaucoup
de violences sexuelles notamment sur les
femmes et pas uniquement et y compris
sur les mineurs la gestion de cette
affaire a été qualifiée de carnage je
cite par une partie de l'opposition
française on rappelle qu'en 2018 dans
une situation quasi similaire Emmanuel
Macron avait refusé à l'époque d'ouvrir
les ports français au bateau que vous
affrétiez avant le stand viking qui
s'appelait l'Aquarius là c'est une
première ce bateau a été accueilli après
trois semaines de difficultés à Toulon
est-ce que vous vous y voyez une forme
de précédent alors non on n'y voit pas
une forme de précédent et puis il faut
peut-être rectifier l'effet en fait en
lorsque Matteo salvidique était émise de
l'Intérieur qui venait de prendre ses
fonctions au gouvernement italien avait
décrété la fermeture des portes
italiennes à ce moment-là c'est les
Espagnols qui avaient tout de suite
proposé au bout de 24 heures d'attente
que le bateau débarque à Valence et donc
nous avions reçu immédiatement une
instruction des autorités maritimes
compétentes et nous nous respectons
strictement les instructions et le cadre
du droit maritime donc nous avions
procédé vers Valence à ce moment-là
c'était très compliqué parce qu'il y
avait 600 personnes à bord plus 600
personnes à bord et donc la marine
italienne avait fait débarquer des
personnes sur deux autres navires on
avait fait une petite flotti pour aller
jusqu'à Valence donc en fait la question
de la France ne s'était pas vraiment
posée contrairement à ce qu'on entend
beaucoup
sauf que le bateau avait dû passer par
entre la Corse et la Sardaigne parce
qu'il y avait une tempête et pour
s'abriter donc on avait dû passer par là
et effectivement on était très proche de
la France à ce moment-là donc la
différence avec cette fois ci c'est que
là nous avons formulé 46 demandes de
port sur pendant trois semaines en
commençant par les pays
compétents c'est à dire la Libye Malte
là où nous avons enfin dans la zone de
compétences de ces pays c'est dans les
eaux internationales mais c'est leur
compétences nous avons procédé à six
sauvetages trois dans les eaux libyennes
de compétences idées 3 les autres
compétences maltaises et ensuite ces
autorités n'ont pas répondu donc là nous
avons escaladé la demande à l'Italie qui
jusqu'en 2018 a été le seul pays
responsable de cette zone de sauvetage
en Méditerranée centrale et qui a
transféré la responsabilité à la Libye
depuis 2018 mais les autorités libannes
sont totalement dans l'incapacité en
fait d'organiser et de coordonnées ces
sauvetages il ne le font pas ils ne
répondent pas et là l'Italie n'a pas
répondu non plus et c'est à ce moment-là
seulement et au bout de très très
longues semaines d'attente puisqu'on est
déjà plus de deux semaines d'attente que
nous avons enfin demandé à d'autres pays
de pouvoir intervenir dont la France on
va arriver dans un instant sur la
position de la France de cette affaire
mais vous avez évoqué une expression
qu'on entend beaucoup et autour duquel
il y a beaucoup de flous cette notion de
port sûr est-ce que cette notion
aujourd'hui concrètement correspond à
une définition juridique très claire
est-ce qu'il y a une liste aujourd'hui
des ports sur vous savez qu'on on
reproche à SOS Méditerranée par exemple
de ne pas débarquer les personnes
récupérées en Tunisie est-ce que la
Tunisie aujourd'hui est un présente des
ports sur pourquoi est-ce que la Libye
est considérée par certains comme étant
une destination qui comporte des ports
sur par l'Italie notamment Salvini à
l'époque avait dit que la Libye pouvait
comporter des portures et voilà donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
que veut dire cette notion effectivement
en fait il y a beaucoup de confusion
beaucoup d'instrumentalisations
politiques autour d'un sujet qui relève
du droit maritime et qui est clair en
fait le droit maritime prévoit deux
choses d'une part que les capitaines ont
l'obligation de porter assistance c'est
une obligation et c'est ne pas apporter
assistance qui est
pénale
une répréhensible finalement donc
l'obligation d'assistance à tout
capitaine qui peut porter assistance à
une personne en détresse et de l'autre
côté les États ont une obligation c'est
les États côtiers ont ces zones de
compétences en mer dans les eaux
internationales donc ça ça va assez loin
de de des autoritariol on est très loin
et là ces pays côtiers ont l'obligation
d'offrir un port à lieu c'est ce que dit
le droit maritime dans lequel la vie des
personnes les plus menacées et leurs
besoins fondamentaux peut-être peuvent
être respectés les opérations de
sauvetage sont censés prendre fin là
l'Organisation Maritime c'est exactement
c'est à ce moment-là seulement dans le
dans le lieu sûr que le sauvetage prend
fin un lieu sûr ne peut pas être la
Libye personne ne dit que la Libye
aujourd'hui peut-être un lieu sûr
peut-être des personnes qui vraiment
essaye de mettre de la confusion sur le
sujet et qui instrumentalise cette
question la Tunisie n'en est pas non
plus la Tunisie en fait n'est pas
indiquée par les autorités maritimes
compétentes nous nous respectons ce que
nous indique les autorités maritimes
compétentes le problème c'est que les
autorités maritimes compétent donc je le
rappelle en l'occurrence la Libye est
Malte n'indique pas ne répondent pas aux
appels ne répondent pas à nos mails nous
avons
inondé de d'appel et de mails ces deux
autorités maritimes compétentes et qui
n'ont pas répondu et donc c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on procède et ça c'est
prévu dans le droit maritime à un
élargissement de la demande aux autres
centres de coordnation des sauvetages
les plus à même d'assister c'est l'IT
qui a coordonné les sauvetages entre les
années 2000 et 2018 et qui a secouru
d'ailleurs des milliers de personnes il
faut le rappeler qu'il y a cette
compétence sur cette zone de l'interdit
centrale c'est pour cela que nous nous
sommes rapprochés de l'Italie avant
contacter l'Italie et n'avons cessé de
demander à l'Italie de pouvoir débarquer
dans un lieu sûr ce qu'elle n'a pas
accepté et donc nous avons dû procéder
encore un élargissement ce sont donc les
autorités maritimes qui donnent ce lieu
sur ce n'est jamais le bateau ce n'est
jamais le capitaine qui décide là où il
doit débarquer comment jugez-vous
l'attitude du gouvernement français dans
cette affaire écoutez nous nous avons
salué l'attitude de la France qui nous a
enfin permis de trouver un port au bout
de 21 jours d'attente c'est inimaginable
ce qui s'est passé à bord on était
vraiment proche de la catastrophe moi je
n'ai cessé d'alerter sur le risque de
perdre ton vie humaine parce que au bout
de trois semaines à bord des personnes
menacées de se jeter par dessus bord la
situation médicale vraiment mauvaise et
surtout d'un point de vue psychologique
les personnes étaient complètement à
bout et vraiment désespéré donc on était
vraiment très très proches
d'un drame qui heureusement n'a pas eu
lieu et il était temps que enfin un pays
ouvre ses portes mais ce n'est pas ce
que nous recherchons et nous n'avons
cessé de le dire évidemment il faut que
les bateaux puissent débarquer les
rescapés au plus proche de la zone
d'opération et pas à l'autre bout de la
méditation vous auriez voulu que ce
bateau arrive en un malt normalement ou
en Italie qui part défaut
prend cette responsabilité de la zone
Méditerranée centrale que répondez-vous
Sophie beau à ceux et ils sont nombreux
qui vous accusent aujourd'hui de faire
le jeu des passeurs là encore nous
répondons que c'est un devoir de
secourir les personnes en détresse et
que c'est indigne d'instrumentaliser
cette question à des fins politiques
comme c'est fait voyons ce qui s'est
passé dans les faits il s'agit de 234
rescapés quand on parle de enfin quand
j'entends tout ce qui a été dit par
certains sur cette situation je trouve
cela révoltant et indigne et honteux en
fait de la part de grands pays qui sont
censés être démocratiques et respecter
le droit de l'homme ce que vous dites
c'est que qu'il y ait des bateaux de
sauvetage ou non que les passeurs le
sachent ou non il y aura toujours des
personnes qui prendront la mer quoi
qu'il en soit ça a été démontré par
plusieurs études en fait quel est le
déterminant qui fait que des bateaux
quittent ces côtes libyenne c'est la
météo c'est à dire quand il fait beau et
que la mer est calme les passeurs sans
scrupules quoi qu'il arrive après même
si deux jours plus tard il y a une
tempête qui arrive pousse ses bateaux à
la mer et c'est à ce moment-là et on le
voit bien y compris quand il y a pas du
tout de navire d' ONG présent que qu'il
y a des départs massifs des côtes
libyennes donc tout cela a été documenté
après chacun dit n'importe quoi
instrumentalise cette question et tout
cela sur au détriment de la vie de
personnes qui sont en danger de mort en
mer il faut le rappeler donc il y a un
impératif du sauvetage en mer et nous
nous restons déterminés et
intransigeants sur cette question il
faut sauver des vies avant tout ensuite
qu'il y ait des considérations
politiques sur que la répartition des
personnes etc bien sûr et c'est le rôle
des États et nous nous ne déplorons que
trop ces atermoiements politiques qui
ont retardé le l'adoption de mécanismes
de débarquement et qui crée des
situations
inextriables comme celle que nous avons
vécu est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que la difficulté et le fait que
plusieurs en tout cas sont ce qui se
passe en mer plusieurs droits
internationaux superposent et peut-être
ce contredise le droit des réfugiés le
droit de la mère est-ce que c'est
peut-être un glouboulga
législatif qui qui empêche les choses
d'être clair mais là encore nous
malheureusement en fait le droit
extrêmement clair mais le droit n'est
pas respecté par les États il est clair
du point de vue du droit maritime et du
point de vue du droit des réfugiés qu'il
est interdit de refouler des personnes
dans un pays dans lesquelles leur vie
menacée et ça c'est aussi écrit dans le
droit maritime donc il n'y a pas de
contradiction c'est ce que les
commentateurs mal informés peut-être
qu'il faut secourir toute personne en
détresse en fait ce n'est pas discutable
depuis le début du mois jusqu'à pardon
aux 6 octobre dernier selon le
Haut-commissariat au réfugiés 1628
personnes sont décédées en Méditerranée
en tentant la traversée ça fait de cette
route la plus dangereuse la route
migrateur la plus dangereuse du monde
combien ce qu'il y a de bateau de
sauvetage aujourd'hui en Méditerranée et
si vous veniez pas qui va et je voudrais
actualiser ce chiffre qui
malheureusement approche des 2000 morts
on est à 1923 personnes qui ont été
décomptées aujourd'hui par
l'organisation internationale
immigration comme décédé en Méditerranée
cette année déjà
en ce moment il n'y a pas de bateau
immunitaire en fait nous sommes nous en
escale technique d'autres sont bloqués
pour des raisons administratives il y a
beaucoup de harcèlement d'autres sont en
escale en fait nous sommes très très peu
nombreux et ce que nous appelons nos
vœux c'est la remise en place d'une
flotte européenne qui puisse
effectivement se déployer sur cette zone
qui est immense face à la Libye on sait
qu'il y a des milliers de personnes qui
fuient ce pays en guerre et en proie au
chaos donc il faut les secourir c'est ce
que la marine italienne avait fait
pendant un an avec l'opération marée
Nostrum entre 2013 2014 et depuis il n'y
a plus de navire pour secourir ces
personnes en fait nous sommes venus
combler un vide laissé par les États et
ça ce n'est pas normal et nous ne
cessons de répéter et d'appeler les pays
européens à prendre leur responsabilité
à mettre en place d'abord des navires de
sauvetage et ensuite à remettre en place
une coordination de ces sauvetages qui a
disparu depuis que la Libye s'est vu
transférer cette responsabilité un mot
les polémique ne vous empêcheront pas de
reprendre la mer non mais écoutez on est
face à une situation militaire
catastrophique moi je trouve ça honteux
scandaleux et on ne peut pas laisser ces
personnes mourir aux portes de l'Europe
je le rappelle on sait ce qui se passe
on sait comment faire pour intervenir et
donc il y a une urgence il faut sauver
ses vies merci beaucoup Sophie bon
d'être venu ce matin sur le plateau de
Paris direct